So next game against Nashville chess
from the USA oh yeah, come on, I'll
play something different.
I somehow lost all of the last E5 games.
I'm going to try the
Kalashnikof
variation here, which I do
n't really know very well or even at all, but that  I
wanted to take a look at it, you always notice that
when trains like this come that you've never
seen before, that you don't
know your way around,
so you have no idea what the idea
is, first do the normal
train again, so if I now pull A6 then
it would
go back again  and then maybe
bishop C4 is an
idea here knight D5 he could also do
if I don't do anything at all,
well I'll just say A6 bishop C4 is of
course always possible but
usually not so dramatic in
this position
I could just ask myself
especially whether on bishop C4 perhaps bishop
simply C4 knight simply C4 knight
simply E4 works
aha goes into one of these makes the typical
schwchnikof
pinning move good play rook
C8 knight C4 is of course now
possible then I wanted knight
B4
answers okay he goes straight to
it  The question is whether this
is dramatic if he really
takes it or whether it actually doesn't
do that much good. Queen f3h3 is
often a problem in such a position.
I play E7 first, I hope
it's not so bad when he
takes it, after all I have it  After that, there was
never a problem again with D5,
so actually I can't achieve much with such a relatively
calm continuation against structure,
but I haven't played something like that for
a while,
okay, he thinks he can do something with
the knight, but well, I
always have bishop
G5
and keep it  So the two bishops, even if
they don't do much at the moment, the
main advantage of the bishop here is that
I can always easily take away knights on E3
when he puts one there,
so of course he still has the
typical G6 F5 ideas
here, you just have to be careful with that
Moment G6 F5 that the bishop
is uncovered here, so it's better not to
use a particularly bad tactic if you want to play calmly,
knight E7 is also easily possible. I do
n't think I know that he'll
achieve so much if he takes it, he'll
probably capture on E7, but  If
you have a big problem, you do
n't have a big problem, okay, he might want to
bring the knight to C4 and then in here, but
that
is often less dangerous than
it
looks, but he has knight
DB6 and then maybe Queen D6, so
quite simply he wants what he wants
I didn't really take that
into account
if I now play bishop E7 he can
beat E7 and then probably
even take D6 hm that's
unpleasant what can I
do I can't think of a good one at the moment
that at least prevents or I mean
defuses knights  D B6 he can
now put the other knight after B6
would then answer B8 and
he can then
step back with B4, well maybe that was
n't a great
idea
but well it's not an easy position
in any
case if he
knight maybe I can  Also put the
rook somewhere else,
well, but you would
n't know where to go, I don't have any spaces
on the cline, the move stone is
definitely
irritating in some way, it invests a lot of time
when it's actually obvious
or do I have
something great there  tur
B8 so now B4 D I have to go
back again so now he has that there a a
concrete question is now F5 does he have
something there I have to do something active ma
here especially since that always looks great but it
is sometimes questionable whether white
can really do something  So he now has the counterattack. The
knight, the bishop is unfortunately
protected here. I could also take it here first,
but I wouldn't really
like to see what happens if I
just
go back to H6. Queen H5.
Maybe that could be a problem.
Well, but I can  Also back to D7
I don't think there's anything
bad
going on here and now I have to
take the opportunity to
play E4 before the box opens
and now it's really
a
bondage again
so unfortunately I can't do much with the
lady,
let's open it  the line, even
if it will definitely take a while to get something there,
so it doesn't seem as if he
has a huge huge number of ideas now,
so Lady
F8 with the idea of ​​Tower
D8, I had the parts a little, oh so
he wants to go to H3  an idea
aha so what's the endgame like now after
Queen
F7 good I don't have that much time I have to
put a little bit of pressure on he does
n't want the endgame
and is still betting on the move
here I don't like going there
but so
cover Queen F6 well  Let's
start again with the F, unfortunately I do
n't have much
time. I don't know if the position is really that
bad,
among other things, knight
G6,
so I got rid of a knight here,
yes, not much happens,
I think I can take the D queen
A7 is a bit unpleasant,
try to do something on the Ginie,
I don't think he can capture it in the rook and
now I have d times1 as a
threat and he doesn't have much on
the bell anymore so maybe Bishop A5
or Bishop
C5 was  Of course it's a bummer, but
both of them only have a very little
time left, ah yes and 2400 times reached, not
bad, yes, quite unclear, it looked
kind of bad for Black
at times, but
I didn't see anything that clear either, yes, it's
always a fight, this
opening